as the presidency of the council of  course we are committed to deal very  responsibly with all that is important  for European Union at this stage with  economy social protection everything  that is linked to migration climate  action but everything we do has the  digital aspect which seems to me it's a  real benefit of being part of Europe is  a connectedness it brings not just our  European neighbors but to the rest of  the world it can mean more engagement  more inclusion bringing more  opportunities to everyone it is our  choice  how we use technology the exhibition  which we are opening here today is a  fine expression of your experience of  your approach and of your ambition it's  about as we already heard how  technological change and digital tools  can improve the lives of all of us